responsive design isn't just about
flexible fluid designs it's also about
adapting to different scenarios and
environments and our primary tool for
doing that is media queries
media queries have their roots in the
media type for style sheets used to
declare a style sheet that's only
applied to certain media types like when
printing
and in the add media section in css
where you can declare a subsection of
the style sheet to only be used for
print or other media for example it's
helpful to display the url of hyperlinks
when printing since you can't click on
the links on paper so that's what this
rule does but css3 media queries added
media query terms this lets us make
conditional rules in our style sheets
based on environmental factors like the
width of the window or the orientation
of the device
this opens up a huge opportunity for us
to make truly adaptive layouts
there are a number of different
properties available inside these media
query expressions like the width and
height of the current window the width
and height of the device
the device orientation the device aspect
ratio and window aspect ratio
whether the device is grid based
how many bits per color the device uses
or whether it's an indexed color device
or whether it's monochrome the overall
resolution of the device and whether
it's progressive or interlaced scan